il existe un piège d'ouverture très
amusant pour les blancs contre la
carrocane pour faire échec et mat en
seulement 6 coups si ça passe ça fait
très plaisir vous allez voir donc on
joue E4 les Noirs font donc C6 le coup
caractéristique de la 44 des 5 on joue
les coups normaux on se déplobe prise
cavalier 17 qui est une des deux grandes
variantes de possibilités c'est de
sortir le four les Noirs veulent jouer
if6 au prochain coup et là on joue le
trémanin dame 2 au lieu de se développer
comme souvent par Caval F3 l'idée c'est
de créer un vis-à-vis contre le roi et
c'est les Noirs ne font pas attention et
joue le coup normal qu'ils ont prévu
cavalier gf6 alors c'est maths sur le
champ cavalier D6 le clouage est fatal
et c'est donc une miniature qui fait
très plaisir